[Musique]
la caravane à vifalure du département
s'installe le temps d'une matinée dans
le quartier de la ZAC avenir à
Saint-Louis des agents de la PMI et des
opérateurs associatifs comme femme 974
et Femmes solidaires actifs dans la
prévention des violences intrafamiliales
viennent à la rencontre de la population
au plus près dans les quartiers le
département continue son engagement du à
les vert donc c'est-à-dire aller au plus
près de la population apporter les
dispositifs du département en fait dans
les différents tierslieux dans les
différents lieux d'écart aussi de l'île
de la Réunion et à travers la caravane
en fait de vifalure nous allons
embarquer à la fois en fait les agents
de la PMI de l'administration et les
association qui s'occupe des violences
intrafamiliales pour pouvoir apporter de
l'écoute du soutien de l'information aux
familles qui sont qui ont besoin d'être
accompagné aux familles qui sont
victimes de violence donc l'idée c'est
de pouvoir à la fois libérer la parole à
la la fois les rassurer leur apporter de
l'information et les accompagner le
mieux possible la première action de
cette caravane a démarré le 15 novembre
à la possession Saint-Louis est la 8e
ville ciblée par ce dispositif porté par
le département de La Réunion plein de
personnes subi V la violence conjugale
et reste dans le silence ils en parlent
pas d'où l'importance d'aller vers et de
les sensibiliser afin que ils peuvent en
parler et sortir de ce silence ben nous
en fait on veut tout simplement montrer
qu'on est là qu'on est disponible pour
aider les personnes en fait sur toute
l'île donc on est basé à Saint-André
mais on intervient sur toute l'île et
pour expliquer aux gens que Ben que les
violences existent et que si elles ont
besoin de parler il y a des gens qui
sont disponibles pour faire une
libération de la parole en fait c'est
c'est ça notre but le dispositif
caravane avifalure est une mobilisation
collective contre les violences
intrafamiliales avec d'une part le
département et ses agents de la PMI les
ISCG les travailleurs sociaux et d'autre
part les associations par enire engagé
sur le terrain contre ce type de
[Musique]
violence